>>> PRIMARY SEASON ENDED THIS
WE'RE ON TO THE GENERAL
ELECTION.
WHEN DEMOCRATS LOOK AT THIS MAP,
THE BATTLE FOR CONTROL OF THE
SENATE, THEY FEEL MORE CONFIDENT
NOW THAN WHEN THE PRIMARIES
BEGAN IN MARCH.
BACK THEN, REPUBLICANS LOOKED AT
THIS MAP AND THEY SAID, MAYBE WE
CAN KNOCK OUT THE DEMOCRATIC
INCUMBENT IN NEW HAMPSHIRE.
THEY THOUGHT FOR SURE THEY COULD
KNOCK OUT THE INCUMBENT IN
GEORGIA.
ARIZONA WAS NOT PLACE THEY SAID
NONPRESIDENTIAL YEAR, WE CAN
BEAT THE INCUMBENT THERE.
AND WE CAN KNOCK OUT THE
INCUMBENT IN NEVADA, AS WELL.
THAT'S HOW REPUBLICANS VIEWED IT
MONTHS AGO.
NOW, DEMOCRATS ARE MORE
CONFIDENT AND REPUBLICANS
ADMITTEDLY NERVOUS, BECAUSE THIS
MAP HAS CHANGED.
A NUMBER OF MAGA, TRUMP-LIKE
CANDIDATES HAVE EMERGED.
REPUBLICANS ARE WORRIED ABOUT
HOLDING A SEAT IN PENNSYLVANIA.
THE INCUMBENT HAS RETIRED.
FETTERMAN IS PREFERRED OVER
MEHMET OZ.
THE DEMOCRATS WOULD GAIN A SEAT
THERE.
CAN REPUBLICANS GET IT BACK?
AGAIN, THEY THOUGHT THEY COULD
WIN IN NEVADA.
CORTEZ MASTO, NARROWLY FAVORED
IN THAT RACE.
THEY THOUGHT IN ARIZONA,
REPUBLICANS THOUGHT THEY WOULD
HAVE A CANDIDATE THERE.
THE TRUMP-ENDORSED CANDIDATE, AN
ELECTION DENIER WINNING THERE.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE MORE
CONFIDENT.
A TOUGH RACE, THEY CAN HOLD
THAT.
YOU COME OVER TO GEORGIA.
A STATE REPUBLICANS WERE MOST
CONFIDENT ABOUT AT THE BEGINNING
OF THE YEAR.
HER
H
HIRSHAL WALKER.
IN NEW HAMPSHIRE, THE DEMOCRATIC
INCUMBENT.
THE RETIRED GENERAL, TRUMP DID
NOT ENDORSE BUT TRUMP-LIKE IN
HIS STATEMENT.
M
MAGA-LIKE IN HIS STATEMENT.
DON WON THAT RACE AND THE TWO
CANDIDATES ON TO NOVEMBER.
>> IF ELECTED, HE WOULD BE MORE
INTERESTED IN PUSHING AN
EXTREME, OUT-OF-STEP AGENDA THAT
WOULD DRAG OUR COUNTRY BACKWARD.
>> WE'RE GOING TO COME TOGETHER
WITH ONE COMMON GOAL.
AND THAT IS TO BEAT SENATOR
HASAN WHO HAS NOT SERVED THE
STATE WELL.
SHE HAS BEEN PROBLEMATIC WITH
THE ECONOMY AND CREATED
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF HARDSHIP TO
GRANITE STATERS.
>> I WANT TO START WITH THAT
RACE IN NEW HAMPSHIRE.
THE REPUBLICAN ESTABLISHMENT
UPSET.
THEY HAD A STATE SENATOR, CHUCK
MORRIS.
THEY THOUGHT HE WAS A BETTER
CANDIDATE, A MAINSTREAM
CONSERVATIVE THAT COULD WIN.
WE SEE JUST TODAY, LET'S LISTEN
TO GENERAL BALDWIN.
TODAY AND A MONTH AGO ON A KEY
QUESTION.
>> LIVE AND LEARN, RIGHT?
I'VE DONE A LOT OF RESEARCH ON
THIS.
THE ELECTION WAS NOT STOLEN.
WAS THERE FRAUD, YES.
UNFORTUNATELY, PRESIDENT BIDEN
IS THE LEGITIMATE PRESIDENT.
>> I SIGNED A LETTER SAYING THAT
TRUMP WON THE ELECTION.
AND DAMN IT, I STAND BY MY WORD.
>> DAMN IT, I STAND BY IT,
BEFORE THE PRIMARY.
YOU NEED THE VOTES FROM ELECTION
DENIERS TODAY.
NEVER MIND.
>> I BELIEVE THEY CALL THIS A
PIVOT, TO THE GENERAL.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS AFTER THE
HARD-FOUGHT PRIMARIES.
YOU HAVE A CANDIDATE AND THEY
HAVE TO FACE ALL OF THE VOTERS
INSTEAD OF JUST THE REPUBLICAN
BASE, WHICH IS WHAT HE HAS BEEN
CONCERNED WITH.
IT'S NOT CLEAR IF HE WILL MAKE
THAT PIVOT, WITH TAPE LIKE YOU
JUST PLAYED, OUT THERE.
THIS IS THE REPUBLICAN IN A
RACE, WHO HAS SAID THAT JOE
BIDEN IS NOT THE LEGITIMATE
PRESIDENT AND THE ELECTION WAS
STOLEN.
HE HAS BEEN THE ONE MUCH MORE
WILLING TO TIE HIMSELF CLOSELY
TO FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP.
AND THAT'S GOING TO BE A FACTOR
IN THIS ALREADY VERY COMPETITIVE
RICE.
AND MAGGIE HASSAN, THE DEMOCRAT,
WAS VULNERABLE GOING INTO THIS.
AND SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT
VOTERS ARE CONCERNED ABOUT ARE
PROBLEMS FOR DEMOCRATS.
THERE'S HIGH INFLATION.
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S APPROVAL
RATING HAS TICKED UP BUT NOT
WHERE DEMOCRATS WANT IT TO BE.
THIS IS A CONTEST THAT DEMOCRATS
WOULD RATHER HAVE WITH A
CANDIDATE LIKE THAT THAN A
CANDIDATE LIKE MORRIS WHO HAD
NOT MADE STATEMENTS LIKE THAT.
>> I TRY TO STAY ON TOP OF THIS.
MR. BOLDUC MADE STATEMENTS.
HAS A LOT CHANGED?
>> NOT THAT I'M AWARE OF.
I IMAGINE THE POLLING SHOWED
SOME SOMETHING A BIT DIFFERENT,
WHEN IT COMES TO PIVOTING FOR
THE GENERAL.
HE'S NOT THE ONLY CANDIDATE.
AND THERE'S A HOUSE RACE, WHERE
KEVIN McCARTHY AND SEVERAL OTHER
MAINSTREAM REPUBLICANS IF YOU
WANT TO CALL THEM THAT, LINED UP
BEHIND MATT MOWERS.
SEVERAL OTHERS HAD LINED UP
BEHIND CAROLINE LaVETTE.
SHE WON.
THE MORE TRUMPY CANDIDATE.
AND NOW, YOU'RE LOOKINGS A CHRIS
PAPPAS, PROBABLY IN A LOT BETTER
POSITION, A DEMOCRAT, NOW THAT
HE IS RUNNING AGAINST SOMEONE
WHO MIGHT BE MORE TO THE RIGHT
THAN THE OTHER CANDIDATE.
>> 7 1/2 WEEKS IS A TON OF TIME.
BUT THE BIGGEST DYNAMIC IS
REPUBLICANS WILL BE ON DEFENSE.
NOT IN A SOLID POSITION THEY
THOUGHT THEY WOULD BE.
IF YOU GO BACK A FEW MONTHS, YOU
CAN GO BACK TO WISCONSIN, A
REPUBLICAN INCUMBENT.
IF YOU'RE A REPUBLICAN INCUMBENT
IN THE FIRST MIDTERM, YOU HOPED
TO HAVE THIS LINED UP A LONG
TIME AGO.
RON JOHNSON, IN 49.
A TOSS-UP RACE THERE.
REPUBLICANS HAVE TO SPEND MONEY
IN A STATE WHERE THEY HAVE AN
INCUMBENT.
YOU MOVE ON TO GEORGIA, THIS IS
THE ONE THE REPUBLICANS WERE
MOST CONFIDENT ABOUT.
WARNOCK, JUST ELECTED.
THAT LOOKS LIKE A COMFORTABLE
LEAD.
AND THE PENNSYLVANIA RACE THIS,
IS ONE EARLY ON, REPUBLICANS
KNEW THEY WOULD HAVE AN ISSUE IN
BECAUSE THE STATE IS SO 50/50
AND THE INBUM KCUMBENT IS RETIR.
REPUBLICANS HOPED TO HAVE THEIR
SEATS CHECKED BY NOW TO INVEST.
BUT THEY'RE ON INVEST IN OHIO,
AS WELL.
IN WISCONSIN.
POTENTIALLY, NORTH CAROLINA.
>> AND MOST OF THE STATES WHERE
THEY'RE ON DEFENSE ARE PLACES
WHERE FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP
ENDORSED THEM THROUGH THE
PRIMARY, GOT THEM ON THE TICKET
AND NOW THERE'S A SCRAMBLE TO
GET THEM THROUGH THE GENERAL,
GETTING THEM TO PIVOT AND TRY TO
GET THEM TO BE MORE AMENABLE TO
BROADER ELECTORATE, NOT JUST THE
TRUMP BASE THAT COMES OUT DURING
THE PRIMARIES.
BUT PEOPLE WHO MAY BE IN THE
MIDDLE.
PEOPLE WHO MAY HAVE VOTED FOR
JOE BIDEN IN 2020 AND VOTED FOR
TRUMP IN 2016 AND ARE UP FOR
GRABS.
THEY DON'T LIKE THE IDEA OF
ELECTION DENIERS BEING PUT INTO
CONGRESS.
NOW, YOU SEE THE PIVOTS.
YOU'RE STARTING TO SEE SOME OF
THE CANDIDATES MODERATE.
IT'S BEEN DIFFICULT AND WE'RE
SEEING IN THE POLLS THEY ARE NOT
ABLE TO PULL IT OFF.